How do you stay close to the Lord when things are going bad?
Well, to me, I think it's a whole lot easier for me to stay close to the Lord
when things are going bad.
My flesh is such that when things are going good, you tend to not need God as much.
I think the whole purpose of God allowing trials in your life is evidence
that He loves us so much that He gives us trials so that we will have a greater dependence upon Him.
It's when we do things in our own flesh and our own strength and our own self-ambition
that we lose track of what is real important in life and we can lose track of our relationship with Him.
It's on the mountains that is the most dangerous, it's in the valleys that we hang on tighter to the Lord.
So my advice to someone going through difficult times is to allow it to drive you to a closer relationship with Him.
Allow it to drive you to a greater level of dependence upon Him.
Climb up on His lap and just allow Him to snuggle with you and tell you how much He loves you and experience that.
He walks through those valleys with you and that's what you can at least for me.
That's what I can tell where my relationship is the strongest is when I'm in those valleys
that's where I'm the most thankful. It's ever fun, it's ever easy, I'm not a masochist or a sadist,
but it is through the valleys that it's through the difficult times.
My wife and I have always sought out difficult times to make ourselves too comfortable.
When we're too comfortable, we have to go, okay, what is it the Lord wants us to do?
I think the devil wants us to be the most comfortable.
Look, what else is the Lord has for us?
Then I need to get on my knees and get in a prayer time for other people.
And it's the valleys that remind me of that. So that's where I'm the most encouraged.